[Music]
you see this year Orlando just got a
tattoo of your face on his neck think of
that I make of the second season of that
So Raven will be coming out July 25th my
dude yes you did I'm sorry she confused
Raven Symone may have dodged that
question about her former co-star
Orlando Browns new ink I don't know what
you're talking about but she did dish on
season two of Ravens home premiering on
June 25th we have four episodes in a row
what are you guys taking us on what kind
of journey this season well we're taking
a lot of different journeys one the
first episode is a two-parter and a
falcon there's a falcon involved no
Larry what there's a falcon you got into
him down a real it was but it was the
Raven and the falcon going at it it was
very interesting we have a musical
episode coming out this season we have
Michelle Williams coming this season we
have rondell Sheridan who played Victor
Baxter coming this season we have so
much happening you're pulling out all
the stops are you gonna be singing in
the musical episode we're both singing
fons are you yeah original songs
original dance moves created by
wildebeest we would do it happening yes
between Raven Molly and me and sky cats
were um we're all talking about our
relationship and how it's gonna change
and twist it up it's a really nice
moment I I that's one of my favorite
moments
[Music]
[Applause]